yellowstone fans get to step into the
dutton family past with taylor
sheridan's hotly anticipated prequel
series 1883 which debuted on december
19th 1883 presents a whole new story
surrounding the ancestors of kevin
costner's john dutton from yellowstone
as they leave texas to find a new life
in montana only to face extreme hardship
on the journey there
you go all these folks hauling ass west
and north and they've never even seen
the country and they don't even know if
it's worth the journey 1883 is the
origin story of yellowstone including
how the dutton family acquired the
largest cattle ranch in the united
states it's a tale that follows the 19th
century duttons as they travel west on a
wagon train through harsh environmental
conditions encountering hostile enemies
at every turn it has not been confirmed
how many episodes the first season of
1883 will have but it will likely be
around 10 similar to seasons of
yellowstone if yellowstone's
record-breaking ratings are anything to
go by then 1883 is going to be a huge
success while the show is sure to be a
hit with viewers it's what happened
behind the scenes specifically with lead
star tim mcgraw while making this
western series that was truly
entertaining according to his castmate
lamonica garrett shot on location in
texas and montana garrett reveals in a
new interview that mcgraw's antics on
the set of 1883 made things extra
interesting between takes the three-time
grammy winner plays james dutton the
great grandfather of costner's
yellowstone character previews show
mcgraw going toe-to-toe with western
gunslingers alongside oscar nominee sam
elliott and garrett who is playing a
character named thomas so what was
mcgraw up to behind the scenes that got
such a kick out of the cast it doesn't
take a rocket scientist to figure out
that tim mcgraw would likely do a little
crooning while on the set of 1883 but
what co-star lamonica garrett didn't
expect was for the country legend to
sing about every little thing under the
sun and on a constant basis to boot cara
told people magazine on set tim sings
every day every day like in between
takes he's just he's humming he's doing
something he sings all the time
according to mcgraw's co-star it didn't
matter what he was doing or what kind of
weather it was the star of the
yellowstone prequel series was going to
get his notes out garrett continued
he'll sing the horse is angry today in a
jingle you know he's a singer and that's
what singers do they sing about their
own stuff and everything else the
upcoming prequel series takes place in
an even more wild setting than
yellowstone with the stronger wild west
feel adding difficulty to the filming
process in fact sam elliott told
entertainment weekly that the first
month of filming which took place in
texas was brutal and frequently 100
degrees
garrett told people this is filmed
outdoors 98 of the time where it'll be
100 degrees and humid or you're in
montana and it's 15 degrees or 20
degrees and it's just freezing from sun
up to sun down add that to constant dust
and sweat and you'd likely welcome some
entertainment to take your mind off of
the intense work so why not listen to a
grammy-winning artist like tim mcgraw
also starring in 1883 is mcgraw's wife
and five-time grammy-winning singer
faith hill who plays margaret dutton the
strong-willed matriarch of the dutton
family and mcgraw's character's wife
although there are no reports of hill
joining in with her husband's humming
and singing that would definitely be
quite the gift for the cast and crew the
couple has been married since october of
1996 making this year their 25th
anniversary mcgrawn hill have worked on
music together and toured many times in
the past but
1883 will be their first official acting
project together taking on this classic
story of a family protecting themselves
and their possessions from the dangerous
world of the late 1800s in america many
people are excited to see the entire
cast of 1883 bring the rich story to
life the first episode of 1883 debuted
december 19th check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the world of
yellowstone are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]